hello everyone I seem to be coming down
with the flu which couldn't happen in
the worst time since there are so many
games between alpha zero and stocked
fish
I am very eager to show you but then
again it's never a good time to come
down with the flu so let's just check
another not a very nice game it's a it's
a her name which features a very old
opening and the position reached in the
game was only once reached before in in
tournament chess which we're gonna
discuss when we get to that position but
since well if you're following any chest
news on the Internet you probably
already read the the academic report the
academic paper from deep mind regarding
deep blue and the updated version of
alpha zero and another metric in stock
fish out of a thousand games you will
also be able to see the result of that
match in the description below where
alpha zero lost only six games and it is
said in that paper that alpha zero also
faced the newest version of stock fish
that was only in development and it also
defeated that version of stock fish with
similar results and also they tried
pairing alpha 0 against stock fish where
stock fish had more time like 10 to 1
and also alpha was able to prevail
the only time alpha was struggling when
stock fish was allowed the use of
opening books their stock fish one a
couple some games with white but still
offers you a warm the match so that
being said do check it out in the
description below there's really a lot
of data I'm sure you're you're all going
to enjoy it so let's get back to this
game so like we said this is out of the
games I received this is a game number 9
I believe where alpha actually has the
black pieces so let's see how it went
we have E for buy stock fish e5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4
so the Italian game is on the board we
have brought up the c5 and here a stock
field goes for B for the Evans gambit I
was trying to make that into into a
nicer joke but I'm just I'm just feeling
to the tool d3 was of course played we
have a six and now stock fish
immediately goes for the weak f7 pawn
Knight the g5
the threat is of course now Bishop
captures and the night captures on f7
and we have night to h6 alpha defense D
f7 pawn and there's no immediate way of
taking advantage of anything here and
this is what I was talking about if you
look at this position it seems like
something that you would expect out of a
two Knights defense where White was
Knight g5 and then black tries to defend
with Knight to h6 I would the difference
of a six and in the d3 being played and
this night Evan never actually came to
have sex but okay regardless this
disposition was only once before reached
and it was in in 1999 in a game between
Michael Palmer and Eckhart Burke so as
you can see it was a it was a game
played between these two gentlemen and
they are rated around 1000 so it's
interestingly that stockfish would white
and offer zero with black go for the
same line as these two gentlemen and
this is the only such game available in
database so it's also important to the
next time you see two gentlemen playing
chess you know you might disregard that
again because they you know that might
be overrated players but who knows they
might be playing out a masterpiece such
as this one and they even though in that
game weiter continued with Queen to f3
allowing night to d4 but white started a
very nice attack and in the end they won
the game here stockfish goes for castle
we have d6 by alpha zero making room for
this light square bishop to be developed
a for a very nice move taking taking
more space on the Queen side preventing
b5 also a5 will be an idea in the future
and now Bishop to g4 this Knight and h6
now actually comes very handy as it
gives protection to the bishop on g4 you
cannot play F 3 because alphas bishop is
pinning the f2 pawn so Knight back to f3
and here it seems awkward this bishop is
threatening to capture the night so and
there's really no good way to move the
knight but alpha doesn't mind he simply
castles and Bishop captures and h6 is
definitely a possibility but neither
alpha nor stockfish are really
considering this first stock this goes
h3
takes away the butter to h5 and now c3
our nice move at in the future before
will be an idea d4 will be an idea and
also it takes away to be Foursquare from
the night and here King to h8 a very
nice move that I don't know I would I
will often play a move like this in
blitz games so when Bishop captures is
eventually played then I will already
have a semi-open file for the rook and
here it seems that alpha 0 does exactly
that
also we done pins and now the f7 pawn
can be played and while this Knight is
an h6 it actually supports the pawn to
be pushed to f5 so in this moment stock
Fischer decides to capture it we have
better captures on h6g captures on h6
and now Knight bTW to stock fish
continues his development now d4 as we
mentioned will be an idea in the future
before will be an idea Knight b3 could
be an idea
so first Alpha retreats with the bishop
not allowing this Bishop on c5 to stay a
target - up to d5 now with ideas of
either pinning the night as the b7 pawn
is a target or even capturing then black
will have a ruined phone structure on
the Queen side as well as on the King
side and here alpha decides to make the
game more interesting night east 7
attacking the bishop on d5 but also
offering the b7 pawn so stop fish
snatches at the Bishop captures on b7 we
have rook to b8 and now even Bishop
captures on a 6 so if you look at this
position stock fish has 8 points
alpha 0 has 6 points he just sacrificed
two pawns on the Queen side and his King
set is completely shattered
so without worrying about material
without considering ideas like rook
capture some B to buy meat surely alpha
considered it but
f5 a very nice idea while you're you
know you just sacrifice 2 points you
want to go for the attack King to h1
stock fish does a similar idea as the
bishop here is pinning the f2 pawn so we
don't want to move the King and it's at
one point if the G pawn disappears then
rook will be able to come to g1 the
counter alphas rooks on the G file
Knight to g6
and now comes a captors on f5 and here
Knight to f4 not again not caring for
material but here
would be a very complicated game if we
captured ng4 is coming the the rook and
Bishop are under attack and here okay
you are losing maybe a piece but why it
would be under tremendous pressure here
but offer things Knight to f4 is better
so Knight to f4 and now d4 closing off
the bishops influence along this
diagonal we have rook captures on f5 now
and now Queen to c2 here alpha a stock
which doesn't even want to go for g4 if
g4 here and then we have this very nice
rook captures on b2 and now if you
capture on f5 then we get rook captures
here you can capture with the night
because the bishop will capture the
Queen so Queen captures and now Bishop
captures with check King h2 and after
Queen to h4 white is getting checkmate
it and it doesn't matter much after look
after some b2 if you capture the bishop
if you capture the bishop then this
Queen to a8 is deadly you will move this
Knight then there will be a double
attack here and whatever whatever white
plays it will simply not be enough if
you try to defend it with Bishop to e2
then rook captures on h5 another threat
is the rook captures and h3 followed by
Queen - Queen to g8 and it's actually a
foursome 1811 here but okay after rook
captures on f5 we have Queen to c2 now
getting the Queen out of this diagonal
g4 becomes a threat once again so now
route back to f8 by alpha we have rook a
to e 1 and now Queen to f6 alpha wants
to go Queen Queen g7 and then checkmates
not fish on G to rock to e3 a very nice
rook lifts introduces the rook into the
defense and now Queen to g7 the threat
is now Queen captures on g2 with
checkmate rook to g1 defending this was
one of the ideas when stock stock which
played King to h1 we have Knight to d5
and now comes the trip to b5 if you move
the rook for example rook e t1 then
black will simply open lines ecaps or
some before and after pawn captures now
Knight to before attacking the Queen and
also the bishop on e6 so this is one of
the problems and if you want to keep
defending the bishop for example Queen
c4 you will get the d5 and now the Queen
will have to go all the way back to keep
defense of the bishop on e6 it will be a
very passive position to play and
stockfish doesn't like it
so after 95 Bishop to b5 and now comes
Bishop to g6 with an attack on the Queen
Queen c1 and now stock alpha decides to
capture the rook we have Knight captures
on e3 and now comes F captures on e3 we
have Bishop to f7 sorry about that
Bishop to f7 and now rook to f1 Bishop
to d5 now comes the ship to see for
countering alphas Bishop and now a bunch
of 2:8 and now as you can see alpha has
a bishop on a7 a bishop on e8 and as you
can see the bishop pair is simply a
monstrosity here
a5 we have E for this efore seems like a
very weird decision but alpha has a very
nice plan it seems seems counter
intuitive to block your own bishop on it
like this by pushing e4 but alphas ad
has to push efore even d5 and then
attack the base of the pawn chain either
by making sure this rook at some point
captures on b2 or after this Knight
moves the Queen will somehow attack the
base of the pawn chain here on e3 so we
have e for nice to h2 and now comes
Queen to g5 so now the e3 pawn is
attacked and here stockfish allows alpha
to capture it b4 if you defend it with
Queen e1 then Queen captures on a5 first
is an idea I first you eliminate this
pawn so white will not have a protected
to pass pawn on a 5-1 stock which pushes
before and after before Queen comes back
the g5 white really doesn't have all
that many moves Bishop b3 black will
exchange here row capture screen
captures and now after this rook comes
into the game and the bishops come alive
wife will have a very difficult position
to play so after Queen g5 b for
immediately protecting the a5 pawn and
rather giving up the e3 pawn so Queen
captures on e3 and now comes Knight to
g4 trying to activate the knight would
an attack on the Queen also on the h6
pawn queen to g5 and now Queen to e1
and now comes h5 with
- III and now even h4 alpha isn't
worried about night back to g4s he does
have another H point to pull back the
night
so after h4 we have Bishop to e6 with
some ideas of controlling the f5 square
so perhaps the bishop to f5 will be an
idea here but after office Bishop to c6
stockfish doesn't go Bishop to a5 rather
he goes back Bishop to c4 and now after
d5 stockfish goes for B 5 B 5 is a very
nice move because you cannot capture the
pond rook captures will simply remove
the defender and then stop fish will
grab the bishop on b5 so after be five
who have rush up to b7 and now Fischer
back to b3
rook beat the c8 and now comes a six
brush up to a eight and now rush up to a
four and here if you try and play
something like c5 which does seem to
make sense you know opening up lines and
make your bishops come alive this will
actually be a very nice draw after
capturing on c6 and pass on row capture
screen captures and now after Bishop
captures Bishop captures rook captures
you will have Queen to f8 check and our
black will have a very hard time getting
out of this check well it will not be
possible after a queen to f5 attacking
the d5 and threatening Queen e5 check
you can parry everything after real
capture so you will simply continue
checking the black king so here I move
like c5 would be and of a draw offer so
Bishop to b6 clink the g1 and now Queen
to g3 here alpha decide stall for a
queen trade as you've seen an active
idea I like c5 does not give off
opportunities to go for a win so Queen
captures H captures and now rook back to
a1 we have looked to f2 attacking the
knight and e2 and now comes Knight to f1
rook to e2 and now Knight back to f5 and
here the g3 pawn is under attack and
there is really no good way for you to
defend it we have looked the g8 the
Knight captures on g3 and now rook to d2
making room for this point to be pushed
at some point we have looked to f1 and
now comes Bishop to a5 going after
the c3 pawn rook to have to recapture
skin captures and Bishop captures on c3
it's very interesting but as long as
this pawn is on d5 and Alpha's Bishop is
on a 8 it doesn't seem like this Bishop
is coming alive anytime soon but this
was an office plan all along
he will eliminate these pawns and then
it will be possible and once again to
reactivate this vision we have h4 by
stockfish group - f8 King - III but now
Bishop to e1 attacking the knight and g3
you cannot move it anywhere since the
night and g3 is also protecting the
night on f5 and here alpha makes just a
brilliant sequence of moves
kingi - Bishop captures Knight captures
and now route back to g8 you have to
play King to f2 to protect the night
otherwise you're gonna lose the G to
pawn so King f2 and now comes Luke to g4
and this is how alpha releases this
light squared bishop from his prison
alphas play this III with check and
there's no way to stop this Bishop the
d1 stockfish attacks alphas rook but now
III would check you cannot capture
because you're gonna lose the night so
first king of three and now rook
captures on d4 and you still can't
capture the pawn because your Bishop is
hanging on d1 so Bishop to e2 and now
comes work to be for going after the
pawns at some point rugby 3 is coming
this point will be pushed to D to block
the bishop and then this rope will pick
up the pawns King captures on e3 we have
d4 with check King moves and now Rock
the beat you check King to e1 you can't
go up for example King D 3 because
rook here checks and the wins the night
so after rugby to check King e1 we have
a rook to b3 attacking the knight Knight
to h5 and now finally d3 eliminating the
defender of the b5 point not eliminating
it but it's no longer defending the b5
point Bishop to d1 rook captures on b5
with Knight to f4 and now rope to a5 g 3
rook captures on a6 we have Knight
captures on d3 and now you can see that
this is a both alpha and stockfish have
two pawns but alpha has a rope
the shrimp against a bishop in the night
so this is by all means winning and
alpha has no problem proving this
proving why this is winning so this is
move already moved 64 and the game lasts
for a hundred moves so as you can see
it's often the case where when two
humans play then the game will often
last much less when one of the players
reaches a winning advantage but here
stockfish defends properly so it will
take alpha sometime we have King King D
- Bishop f7 g4 and now alpha starts
activating his King night f2 we have
rook to e8 Bishop to e2 and the rook to
a4 now going after the pawns
Bishop to d1 we have looked to d4 check
King III and now after a couple of more
moves where alpha is going all around
trying to trying to trick stop there
stop fish defense properly but at one
point you can see that slowly slowly but
surely stop fish is making concessions
and now after h5 has been played now
stock fish has a light square bishop and
both of his pawns are on light squares
and now sooner or later this King will
make his trip all the way to g5
threatened to capture the g4 point and
as alpha also has a light square Bishop
alpha will assist the King in capturing
the g4 pawn so 91 we have Bishop 287
Knight be to kingi 794 rope to a
six-night e5 King to f6 97 check King to
g5 now the King is in position and now
all that's left is for this Bishop to to
join the attack against the g4 pawn
snatch the pawn and then it's a winning
game Bishop e2 we have grouped to e6
check King to f2 and after rook to e7
it was in this position actually unmoved
97 I missed when I said 100 is when
stockfish resigned the game why the
stock is resigned well after the knight
moves the plan is simple you will simply
kick away the night then prepare to
prepare a move with the bishop and then
after one more move you will play
something like much of the d5 Bishop is
coming to e6 and then you will at some
point capture here and then it's a
completely winning game
so yeah I have to look to his seven
stockfish to resign the game and I
really do hope you enjoyed this is it
almost featured an Evans gambit have a
nice Italian game and like I said after
this knife to h6 I was a game only once
played in chess history between mr.
Michael Palmer and Eckhart Burke
gentlemen rated 1000 so like I said
whenever you see someone playing a chess
game they could be playing out a
masterpiece
I swear now I would like to thank Bruce
Cummings Purvis Katya seventh day on
footage johannes broad wall and the mick
grammatical for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I was you soon with another very nice
alpha verse to stop this game thank you
all and I will see soon